all right st patty's day is on thursday
and pink box is going green so let's
welcome michelle and pastry chef anna to
help us get into the spirit hey ladies
hi there hi hi thank you first and
foremost for bringing all these donuts
of course of course i'm in heaven right
now so let's start first with the lineup
for st patrick today what is on the menu
what can people enjoy perfect so we
debuted on march 1st our st patrick's
day we have over 11
brand new and fun little twists on some
of our old faithful favorite okay we've
got minty with a little irish flag we've
got a pot of gold a an irish diva an
irish unicorn
i know it's a pot of gold well what's so
fun about our st patrick's day london is
we do have some irish elements such as
of course the flag and the
uh pot of gold gold sprinkles all kinds
of fun goodies the clover of course the
clover of course and green obviously um
so let's move over here pastry chef yes
so show me how it's done so
of course we always start with the blank
and then we we dip it in one in our
green icing so we thought it'd be fun
for you to do this so we're gonna try
with us too all of our decorations
already do not know what to do
so you're just gonna grab well you are
right-handed so you're gonna grab your
pastry bag with your strong hand okay
okay so we're gonna start with a center
you just put a little dot in the center
little dot in the center yeah wow i'm
already not doing great i'm better at
eating i'm better eating doughnuts guys
eating donuts okay go ahead and then i
always say like let's make hearts let's
make hearts where do you find your
inspiration when it's holidays or you
know a special occasion how do you do
that i think it's it's you know some of
our old favorites we do um
we hear a lot from our customers we uh
bring back some of the ones that are
really really people love exactly called
for things like that so
you know what i'm not you're doing i'm
not dead
i'm over here supposed to be conducting
an interview but i'm getting very
serious about this and forgetting that i
have to ask you questions too okay we've
got some amazing decorators oh my gosh
and these are all hand done
this is fun okay so there we go there we
go good job you know my hearts don't
look like clovers but it's kind of like
the rock and roll version that's right i
don't know that's right
this is beautiful thank you okay and of
course it is march yes you have a donut
of the month introduce us right so let
me think about it is back by popular
demand it's one of my new favorites
every month i have a new favorite of
course but it's a pistachio cake
doughnut for anybody that loves
pistachio it's a delicious
with a pistachio cream cheese
buttercream on top one yes
you better have a nipple we're showing
you pictures of it now yeah oh my gosh
so just describe
the flavor for pistachio people it's
definitely an acquired yes yes yeah and
you actually don't even have to be a
pistachio lover honestly it it's very
hint but it's so good it's not
overpowering yeah it's the perfect
balance yeah
well there are several pink box
locations you guys have to how long can
they get the
until march 17th end of day march 17th
everybody go out and get them but don't
end up
okay we'll be right back